temps monsieur
pierre lellouche
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
premier ministre
après les déclarations de monsieur
ayrault la semaine dernière devant la
commission des affaires étrangères
réunis à huit clos je souhaiterais vous
interroger sur deux points de notre
politique étrangère qui on a un impact
direct sur la lutte antiterroriste en
libye d'abord
alors que nous soutenons officiellement
le gouvernement sa rage à tripoli nous
apprenons que des forces spéciales
françaises combattent de l'autre côté du
pays avec le général haftar son riva
nous avons d'ailleurs perdu trois
soldats au mois de juillet alors
première question quelle est la
politique de la france en libye
deuxième question quelle est la
politique de la france en irak le 24
septembre 2014 et le 13 janvier 2015
alors que vous demandiez ici même
l'autorisation du parlement pour
intervenir en irak vous nous aviez
explicitement spécifié que
l'intervention française serait
uniquement aérienne et accessoirement
porterait sur la formation de
combattante pêche méga je vous cite vous
aviez dit nous n'engagerons pas de
troupes françaises au sol or nous
apprenons par la bouche de monsieur
ayrault que depuis quelques jours en
plus des 500 hommes qui sont déjà en
irak nous venons de déployer une
batterie d'artillerie avec la force de
protection de 150 soldats donc nous
sommes en train de changer d'époque et
vous êtes en train de mettre le doigt
dans un engrenage qui s'appelle la
participation de la france à des
opérations au sol en irak la question
c'est est-ce raisonnable pour la france
de participer à côté des forces
iraniennes irakienne et du hezbollah à
une guerre contre les sunnites est-ce
que c'est raisonnable est ce que c'est
notre intérêt national
cela mérite débat vous avez outrepassé
l'autorisation qui vous a été donné l'an
dernier nous vous demandons monsieur le
premier ministre de respecter la
constitution et d'ouvrir ce débat devant
la sienne de l'assemblée nationale comme
l'exigé l'article 35 alinéa 2 de notre
constitution merci la parole est à
monsieur jean yves le drian ministre de
la défense
monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs le député monsieur le député
lellouche
notre intervention au levant repose sur
des bases juridiques claires et des base
constitutionnelle solide
lorsque le gouvernement dans sa
déclaration du 15 septembre 2015 avait
décidé l'engagement des forces aériennes
il avait expressément exclu une
intervention au sol en syrie cette
exclusion avait été réitérée au moment
du vote d'autorisation le 25 novembre
2015 par contre
la prolongation de l'intervention des
forces françaises en irak accordé par le
parlement le 13 janvier 2015 ne fait pas
une telle distinction est le premier
ministre avait en outre explicitement
indiqué que le dispositif français dans
ce pays continuerait d'évoluer il ya
d'ailleurs eu depuis nombreux mois des
éléments terrestres en charge de la
formation et de soutien à l'armée
irakienne est donc le déploiement d'une
unité d'artillerie dans la région de
mossoul est simplement une extension du
mode opératoire de l'engagement défense
française en irak en soutien des forces
irakiennes la nécessité d'un vote du
parlement n'est donc pas avérée en
revanche il importe d'informer le
parlement de l'évolution de la situation
c'est ce que j'ai fait moi-même le 26
juillet dernier devant les commissions
de l'assemblée nationale et du sénat
j'ai pu faire un point complet des
opérations extérieures au levant y
compris l'usagé des canons caesar dont
vous faites dont vous avez parlé il y a
un instant le compte-rendu en ligne de
ces séances en témoignent sur la libye
puisque vous y avez fait référence je
voudrais vous dire que la position de la
france a toujours été de soutenir le
gouvernement d'union nationale et
concernant l'allusion que vous laquelle
vous faites allusion sur les actions
militaires il n'y a pas d'action
militaire en garde et actions de
renseignements que la france mène comme
dans d'autres régions du monde et pour
ce point je suis à la disposition de la
délégation parlement la parole est à mme
adam